so our next speaker is Ray Bradley Reyes
director of the climate system Research
Center at the University of
Massachusetts Amherst and a university
distinguished professor in the
Department of geosciences there his
interests are in climate variability and
why climate changes over a large range
of timescales ray is very famous for his
work to reconstruct the temperature
record over the past 1,000 years and
today he'll speak on Holocene Arctic
climate variability past present and
future
thanks actually I was I was but I
thought it might be interesting to look
at the the issue of recent change future
change and the in the context of the
past statement from the various leading
economies that they recognized the
increase in global average temperature
should be maintained or limited to no
more than two degrees Celsius above
pre-industrial levels and the European
Commission and other economies have
adopted this strategy to try to limit
co2 emissions to the point where global
mean average temperature globally
averaged temperature annual temperature
should not rise to more than two degrees
C above pre-industrial level and I want
to just think about that issue with
respect to the Arctic and with respect
to the co2 changes that were envisioning
for experience so this is a
reconstruction by Darrell Kaplan and
others of Arctic temperature over the
last 2000 years this is the whole Arctic
so including Siberian North America and
so on and what you see here are the
inter annual variations with some
uncertainties associated with it the red
here is is all we know from
instrumental period so if we didn't have
any Paleo climate reconstruction this is
all we would know about arctic
temperatures and what we see here and
this by the way is with respect to the
average for 1961 to 90 so these are
deviations positive or negative with
respect to that mean and there are a
couple of other earlier reconstructions
over peck at Al and here's the
instrumental data as I said the dominant
feature of this record as you can see is
it is a slow decline followed by this
sharp rise this is the the in an earlier
iteration this was referred to as a
hockey stick type of shape the question
is what drove that long-term decline in
temperature I'm look just looking at the
very lowest frequency and the answer is
orbiting forcing that's related to
so-called Milankovitch changes and in
particular the timing of the precession
of the equinoxes which defines the time
at which the earth is closest to the Sun
and if we go back to the early Holocene
eight 10,000 years ago the earth was
closest to the Sun during the Northern
Hemisphere summer
today we're closest to the Sun in early
January and what that earlier early
Holocene changed and as a result of
precession led to is significantly more
energy impinging on the atmosphere
during the summer at high latitudes and
I'll show you that what this attempts to
show I'll have to explain this a little
bit here's the months of the year and
each panel shows the anomaly of energy
the the surplus or the deficit of energy
relative to today so if the if the
values if the color is red there was a
lot more energy than here's the sky
at the bottom here and watts per square
meter this is 60 watts per square meter
and each panel shows the variation
averaged around the globe from ten
thousand years to the present going from
ninety degrees north to ninety degrees
south so if we go to July for example
here 90 degrees north ninety degrees
south ten thousand years ago to the
present you can see that in the high
latitudes in the early Holocene there
was a lot more radiation being received
over the Arctic region and that declined
through the Holocene by contrast let's
just pick another month here let's say
November here there was less energy
between the equator and 60 North and
that slightly increased over time and
the the the similar thing happened in
the southern hemisphere so you can see
that every month is different but during
the summer months particularly May June
and July in the early Holocene at high
latitudes there was a surplus of energy
and that declined through time so in
higher temperatures in the early
Holocene and if and if we take this the
regression line and we extend it back in
time to seven or eight thousand years
ago what we find is that temperatures
were about two degrees Celsius warmer
than the pre-industrial levels which
here I'm defining as say 1600 to 1800 ad
so as a result purely of orbital forcing
the early Holocene was warmer than the
pre-industrial level by about the amount
that we're talking about for the the the
post-industrial ear the the limit that
the industrialized nations are talking
about for the future and
we're already warmer than that of course
by about half a degree or so so we're
really talking about the this early
Holocene being about one point six
degrees Celsius higher than now we all
have heard about Arctic amplification
and this is a figure from a paper that
gift Miller and Julie Brigham Greddy
published I don't believe this figure by
the way but I put it up anyway nobody
ever gets that an r-squared of 0.99
that's the first thing soon as I see
that I say well this can't be true so
but anyway the the argument is that if
you plot global temperature temperature
anomalies here versus Arctic temperature
anomalies there is an amplification of
about three point four times so arctic
temperatures warm three and a half times
faster or greater than northern
hemisphere temperatures and these are
various periods in the past last glacial
maximum Holocene thermal maximum little
ice a last interglacial and so on so
let's just accept that that's true for
the time being of an amplification of
about three three and a half if we look
at the model simulations this is now
latitude on this axis from thirty to
ninety degrees north and this is a
various I P C C models each line
represents a different model and it
shows the polar amplification of mean
annual temperature relative to the
global mean for two times co2 so what
does that mean it means that as we go to
higher and higher latitudes here the
temperatures rise relative to the global
average
so with two times global warming is here
three times the average of global
warming is here so you can see that as
we get north of about say seventy
degrees north the amplification factor
in the models is two to three times
which would support the idea of Julie
had for the longer time period but this
is mean annual temperature mean annual
time
we can look at another set of models and
what this shows is these Arctic climate
impact assessment models which was
selected because they represent the
Arctic pretty particularly well if we
look at the global rise in temperature
from 2000 to 2100 here and compare that
with the Arctic rise in temperature over
the same interval again the Arctic seems
to warm up about twice as fast as the
global mean for this particular emission
scenario but again this is mean annual
temperature now we look here's a bunch
of different models on each of these
panels we have latitude from 19 or 290
south we have months of the year from
January to December and what you see is
most of the these colors are temperature
anomalies for a two times co2 what we
see mostly is that it's not the sump
it's not the summer months that are
warming it's the winter the fall and the
winter months and if we focus in on the
summer months we see a quite different
picture altogether and I've just cut out
from this picture all of the summer
months so now we're going from from June
to August at high latitude so this is 90
North to I think 60 60 north and what
you see is that those colors which we
saw here including going all the way up
to 10 degrees C in red are now all at
the other end of the spectrum and in
fact most of the summer in the summers
in the Arctic in all of these different
models are on the range of 0 to 1
degrees Celsius so the summer warming in
the models is much much less than the
mean annual temperature anomalies that
we expect we look at a few more
specifically so we can look at the joy
this this is the Four Seasons his 2011
to 2013 through to 2017 to 2090 and you
can see clearly if we look at the colors
that it's the arctic here which is
changing in the summer months very very
little and it's it's simply because all
that heat is being soaked up by the the
snow in the ice and it's mostly in the
autumn and the winter months where that
warming is taking place here's the what
we've seen over the last century or
millennium or so here's the
pre-industrial levels here's the early
Holocene if if warming from this point
on was three times the global average
we'd be off the scale here two times
Celsius warmer would mean a warming in
the Arctic of six or seven degrees
Celsius but that would be a mean annual
temperature this reconstruction is
summer temperature so we've seen from
those earlier models earlier examples
that the warming in summer is likely to
be much less probably on the order of
two degrees C or or 1 times the global
average temperature not three or four
times the global average temperature so
that would place the the expectation for
later this century to be summer
temperatures in the Arctic would be
similar to the early Holocene values
that we don't we saw look at the early
Holocene as an analog for what might be
in store for us
here's a few examples from northern
Siberia that the treeline migrated north
this is large this is birch maximum
forest expansion was between five to
eight thousand years BP in fact because
the the the the sea level was out here
somewhere
so the
the tree line actually reached the the
northern coast of Siberia at that time
if we look at an ice cap ice core record
from northern Ellesmere Island this is
Agassiz ice cap eighty degrees north six
or seven thousand feet above sea level
you can see this is the melt that was
taking place on the ice cap in the early
Holocene that ice cap was melting away
just as we see parts of southern
Greenland today and recent warming here
this is the last 25 years shows that we
are now approaching melt values that
were typical of the early Holocene at
high latitudes in several different
records of sea surface temperatures in
the Norwegian Sea going from 10,000
years to the present you can see all of
these show a maximum of temperatures in
the early Holocene so there was a
stronger North Atlantic drift and in
fact up here all the way up in small bud
we there were blue mussels the mytilus
edulis was common in the early Holocene
this disappeared over the last few
millennia and it's just started to
reappear the last time mytilus edulis
was found in small but was during
medieval time and now it's just been
found to be recolonizing so we're
starting to see the the changes in this
part of the world that were quite common
in the early up on northern Ellesmere
Island here we have ice shelves today
these limit the penetration of driftwood
and to the coast and yet if we go back
to the early Holocene these these are
radiocarbon dates on driftwood from
Phillips inlet which is over here and
ward hunt which is over here you can see
the driftwood was penetrating into that
those coastal areas in the early
Holocene and it was only in the late
Halle see in the near glacial when these
ice shelves formed and it basically
blocked off
the coast from receiving driftwood into
those fields and by the way a remarkable
fine here on northern Ellesmere Island
was a narwhal tusks which dated 67 a
hundred years ago so there were now wall
that were inhabiting this coast you
would never see now all in this part of
the world anymore there's just too much
ice so presumably there was a lot less
sea ice at that time and finally there
were boat bowhead whales extensively in
the inter-island channels in the early
Holocene we started to see bowheads in
that area too today but there were
certainly both Pacific and Atlantic
bowheads in this region in the early
hosan so there was a lot less sea ice so
and this is the this is part one of my
presentation by the way don't get
carried away so here's the conclusions
on that paleo climate records in the
Arctic reflect summer condition sorry
reflecting summer conditions point to
insulation forcing as the primary factor
in long term changes early Holocene
summer temperatures were two degrees C
above the pre-industrial level and
that's probably what we're going to see
with two times co2 in the summer months
in the Arctic certainly the winter will
be a lot likely to be a lot warmer and
and therefore the early Holocene might
be a good analog of conditions that
might prevail in the Arctic later this
century now what I would like to do and
this is just because Julie suggested it
there's a lot of archaeologists here I
would like to just another quite
interesting story this is a sediment
record that tells us something about
human occupancy of the Norwegian coast
this is up in the Lofoten Islands this
is a beautiful reconstructed Viking
settlement at
org and we did some work this is up here
in northern Norway we did some work
right around the Viking settlement this
is this is a lake called little uns wot
net the the Viking Museum is over here
what we were interested in trying to
determine is could we see could be
separate climatic and human impacts in
the sedimentary record so we took some
cause from Leland's VAT net this was the
Viking chieftains domain so to speak
there was a connection here to the sea
and he brought his Viking boats into
this into this shallow lake but there
were also farms around Leland's batma we
have very good radiocarbon control I
won't go into the details we also have
tephra that we were able to link to
Icelandic eruptions so we have extremely
good chronology on this traditionally
measures of human influence on the
environment use these kind of things
they look at magnetic susceptibility
which tells you something about soil
erosion landscape disturbance pollen of
course was a crucial parameter for
looking at vegetation changes resulting
from human impact charcoal as a result
of fire often by due to human activity
and then also perhaps connected with all
of this changes in sedimentation rate
which might be related to anthropogenic
activity the problem with all of these
is there they could also be due to
natural disturbance this could be due to
more rainfall for example the fire could
be natural the climate could change and
the pollen would would vary and so on so
it's difficult to separate human and
climatic this is a pollen diagram done
by borin from the area around the lake I
won't go into the details six Isis
to say that if we look in detail trees
started to decline maybe 3,000 years ago
and grasses started to increase that's
really all you need to know from this
pollen diagram there was a change in the
fundamental distribution from trees to
grasses why was that due to human
activity or not what we did and when I
say we of course I don't mean me because
I I wouldn't even know how to turn these
machines on but my student Rob d'Anjou
looked at these various biomarker
proxies and I'll just mention what these
are these are sterols Co pristine
all-campus tonal which are related to
human [ __ ] an animal ship basically poop
and what happens is in the digestive
system of animals and people this
material is produced it gets passed
through onto the landscape where people
poop on the landscape and then it gets
washed into the lakes as you'll see in a
minute we also looked at poly aromatic
hydrocarbons which are formed during the
combustion of organic material and these
various alkanes and the different carbon
chain lengths which relate to either
trees or grasses so these are the
various proxies we use to try to
identify the human footprint so to speak
on the landscape so here's the record
seven thousand year record Co pristine
all is produced by humans almost
exclusively actually humans and pigs
produce coke Rosten all what you see in
this record from 7,000 years ago to the
present
no copra style at all and then suddenly
around I think it was twenty twenty-five
hundred years or so ago suddenly Co
pristine all appears in the landscape in
the sediment so people arrived in this
area and started pooping as they would
not that not there's connection between
a rival and pooping but it could be if
we look at stigmasterol this is produced
by grazing animals cattle and other
herbivores you can see that it's not
zero from 7,000 years ago but it's
pretty flat and this reflects the
presence of deer and moose in this area
but you also see at the same time it's
suddenly increased very dramatically
when people arrived in the landscape so
there is the total of these two over
time notice also these poly aromatic
hydrocarbons this is a index of biomass
burning nothing going on are very little
perhaps some natural fires above the
zero here and then as people arrived it
goes up and up as you might expect they
come in they start burning the trees to
provide grazing areas and here's the
carbon chain length index these higher
numbers represent trees and you can see
the the tree vegetations declines
especially after people arrive towards
the president now it's predominantly a
grassland shrubby kind of environment
now let's just blow blow up the latter
part of this so ignoring the pre
occupancy period now look at the
variations that have occurred over the
last 2,500 years and if we look at Co
pristine all and stigmasterol these are
the poop indicators look at the totals
here you can see that it reaches a
maximum around about 450 ad changing the
timescale here could be ca D 450 ad
suggesting that this was the time of
maximum poop production maximum
occupancy presumably then there was a
period which in in this
this part of the world is known as the
Merovingian depression this is a
migration related to social and
political upheaval in the area and the
population declined over that period and
as as one might expect so did the poop
in the landscape later on there was the
Black Death
I think 80% of the farms in this area
were were abandoned at that time and
then we we move into the Little Ice Age
period here which interestingly has the
highest burning signal so presumably
people were those people who were living
here burned a lot of peat and other
biomass simply to keep warm and we also
reached the minimum tree index in the
landscape to my question when I looked
at there was why are these variations
what are these ups and downs really
related to we can perhaps ascribe some
of this to socio-economic factors
political factors perhaps to singular
events like the Black Death summer
temperature reconstruction which is
shown here in blue based on tree rings
from this area and I've superimposed
that here on the COPE Rosten all record
we we had to adjust this by an 80 year
lag but that's well within the dating
uncertainty of this record but you can
see there's a remarkable fit here
between the fluctuations of summer
temperature and the the record of copra
standoff of course we don't have a we
can't link the COPE Roston all entering
the sediment to the population but the
the suggestion here is that the human
population was closely linked closely
affected by the fluctuations in summer
temperature and remember we're up at
about 68 degrees north here we're really
at the limit of farming bali farming
what was was practiced here but it was
really at the growing degree day limit
so a small change in summer temperature
here probably had quite a big impact on
their ability to survive so biomarkers
from human and animal feces can provide
definitive evidence of human activity in
the region where there is when there are
no people you will not find Co frost at
all in the settlement human activity can
be traced through biomass burning and
vegetation composition in this part of
the world population expanded and human
impact on the landscape began around
2250 BP that's when farmers migrated
from the southern part of Norway along
the coast and began to settle in the
Lofoten Islands population was strongly
influenced by changes in summer
temperature as well as by societal
factors and I think fecal biomarkers
offer a unique opportunity to identify
and trace the presence of people in the
landscape and I think this new technique
could be used in many other
archaeological settings I've suggested
in a recent proposal to try this in the
Faroe Islands for example I think it
could also be applied in places like
Rapa Nui Easter Island and other places
where there's still some controversy
about when people actually first arrived
in an area and I'll stop there